The world is charged with the grandeur of
God.
It will flame out, like shining from shook
foil;
It gathers to a greatness, like the ooze of
oil
Crushed. Why do men then now not reck his
rod?
Generations have trod, have trod, have trod;
And all is seared with trade; bleared, smeared
with toil;
And bears man’s smudge and shares man’s
smell: the soil
Is bare now, nor can foot feel, being shod.
And yet for all this, nature is never spent;
There lives the dearest freshness deep down
things;
And though the last lights off the black West
went
Ah, morning, at the brown brink eastward,
springs—
Because the Holy Ghost over the bent
World broods with warm breast and with ah!
bright wings.